you can now access all of the sequence
read archive x' vast public and
controlled access human datasets in the
cloud transforming any laptop into a
high-performance computing device and
the skinnies struggles with speed and
storage issues you might encounter using
FTP to download large datasets from the
NCBI this short video demonstrates the
steps needed to access public SRA data
with Amazon Web Services at the end of
the video you can link to a companion
video describing access through Google
cloud platform
I'll cover these three activities
setting up a new cloud instance
downloading and installing the SRA
toolkit within your instance and
configuring and testing the toolkit
installation to setup a new cloud
instance start with Amazon Elastic
Compute cloud or ec2 if you are new to
AWS or just want to try out accessing
SRA data the free tier is a good option
I've now logged into my account and I'll
launch a new instance for this demo I'll
select the first Linux server except the
t2 micro instance type and go to review
and launch
I'll accept the defaults but be aware
that you may want to edit the security
group and make sure that the region is
set to us - East - one in Northern
Virginia this will give you efficient
and free data retrieval from the SRA ok
I'll click Launch select a key pair
option and in a few minutes my instance
is running I'll connect to my instance
using an SSH client following the Handy
instructions right here the next steps
are to download and install the SRA
toolkit and those steps are nicely laid
out in our github wiki at NCBI /sr a -
tools
including installing and configuration
I downloaded and installed the latest
version 2.10 point three
and now I want to show you in detail how
to configure the toolkit because there
are a few critical steps required to
access these public data in the cloud
type VDB - config and - I to get an
interactive display for the
configuration the first requirement is
to enable remote access which should be
selected by default you can navigate
this config menu either by tab or
underlined letter type C and you can
decide whether you want data cached
locally or not and where you want it
cached if local cache is enabled be sure
that you specify a directory with
sufficient disk space the next two
settings are critical type a to set AWS
as the cloud provider and type R to set
report cloud instance identity that's it
for the configuring process I'll type s
then o to save and X to exit if you want
to review these steps in more detail see
section five toolkit configuration on
the github wiki page let's run a quick
test of our toolkit installation type
faster q - dump and an S are our
accession this run takes several seconds
to retrieve
and there are the two fast queue files
that's all for this demo we'd love to
have your feedback and questions so for
help with SRA data and the toolkit right
to SRA at NCBI NLM NIH gov and for
feedback and other questions please
write to suggest at NCBI
NLM NIH gov